the last man battalion have long since
disbanded after the death of their
leader
charles bliss some of the lmb soldiers
joined with other organizations
like the rikers and cleaners some even
joined the jtf
but the bulk of their remaining forces
were given the opportunity to take
revenge on both the jtf and the division
and joined with the black tusk creating
a new branch in the btsu
but let's turn the clock back a few
months when the l b were at their
strongest
how would they fear against one of the
most brutal washington dc factions
the true sons
after the events of black friday the
dollar flu quickly found its way into
washington dc
amongst the chaos and panic the jtf
attempted to control the spread of the
virus
by setting up a quarantine on roosevelt
island
colonel anton ridgway was given the
responsibility to administer the
quarantine and ensure everything ran
smoothly he was there to make sure that
the people were getting the food
water and the medical help they needed
[Music]
however over time ridgeway grew tired of
witnessing the growing levels of tragedy
and despair from the front lines
he started losing faith in the
government and the jtf's ability to save
washington dc
after coming to the conclusion that
there was no way that anyone would
survive
if they were to continue with their
current way of doing things ridgeway
decided it was up to him to make the
hard calls
and ensure the well-being of his men as
a strong believer in the need for
authority and discipline
ridgeway decided to take matters into
his own hands on roosevelt island
in frustration and fear for the city's
future he deployed guards around the
quarantine
with the order to not let anyone out he
started to redirect resources coming
into the quarantine
withholding medicine and letting people
starve to death
in his eyes the sick and weak were
already dead so his number one priority
became to secure the future of his own
men
ridgway's actions were tainted by his
willingness to do whatever it took for
the well-being of his soldiers
and his repulsion of the sick due to the
chaotic state of the city he was able to
abuse his authority for a long time
before the commander of the jtf found
out
and he was imprisoned however it didn't
take long until loyal members of his
unit freed him
according to the true sons survival of
the fittest is the only way to survive
in washington dc
the last man battalion or lmb is a
private military company
founded by charles bliss a highly
decorated former officer of the united
states army's special forces
composed almost entirely of former
commandos from the army's elite 75th
ranger regiment
and the cia's much special operations
group
the lmb employs some of the most highly
trained and lethal mercenary soldiers in
the world
before the green poison hit the streets
of new york the lmb was deployed in
classified locations across the western
side of asia and north africa
but after the outbreak a number of wall
street businesses came together to hire
them to protect their servers and
physical assets
which were stored deep inside the lower
manhattan quarantine zone
as panic in the financial district began
to spiral out of control
the lmb leader bliss began to clash with
local authorities
their actions or lack of had no place in
a war zone
eventually the quarantine was
established and when the jtf were pulled
back
the lmb found themselves abandoned
after a number of days being cut off and
subjected to the brutal aftermath of a
city that was left to fend for itself
bliss decided that the only course of
action was to retake new york city
himself
and establish a new martial order
but bliss didn't only disobey a direct
order he executed the jtf officer in
charge
the lmb are convinced that not only the
city but the entire nation would
collapse
under the chaos that is unfolding during
the pandemic and it is them who would be
there to help america come out of this
and see the other side
their objective is to gain full control
of new york and then use their newly
created city state as a base to create a
new world order
one where only those with strength of
will and character survive
both the true suns and the lmb have
quite a number of roles within their
ranks
their snipers tanks and heavy weapons
experts all have a military background
but where things start to differ is
where the true suns have spent a fair
amount of time bolstering their ranks
with civilians
and various professions with little
combat experience
on top of this due to a mutual agreement
with aaron kina a number of former
division agents turned rogue
have joined the lmb forces as squad
leaders or commanding officers
as stated earlier the last man battalion
is built up almost entirely of former
commandos from the army's elite
75th ranger regiment and the cia's
special operations group
these troops are among some of the most
highly trained soldiers in the world
where the true sons former jtf are
composed of not only national guard
and other military branches but police
officers
first responders and civil volunteers
also as their influence and territory
spread they conscripted a number of
inexperienced personnel into their ranks
like ex-cons cage fighters hunters
and engineers the trosons wield a number
of government-issued weapons
ranging from smgs assault rifles and
lmgs
to marksman rifles and shotguns
on top of this some of the x army
personnel have brought along rpgs
to add a bit more of a punch to their
output
engineers with backgrounds in
manufacturing and assembly provide
further support in the form of personal
turrets
of which they will put their life on the
line in order to keep them operational
but they aren't afraid to scavenge from
rival factions to add to the arsenal of
technology and have a wide range of
military and homemade equipment
although not always the case with
private military companies the last man
battalion have spared no expense
in equipping their troops with the
latest and greatest weapons and military
gear
they are far more heavily armed than
even the most well-funded military corps
and this is only further supported by
the rogue division agents who provide
field support
and the advanced shd tech and weaponry
with the lmb engineers and their
experience in engineering and robotics
they've been able to reverse engineer a
number of pieces of shd technology
and bring it over to their side
the trusons rely on suppression tactics
and snipers to pick targets off from
range
but alternatively they also utilize riot
foam and shotguns
to slow threats down and eliminate from
close quarters
their snipers are methodical and know
how to effectively use cover
throwers will try to keep their distance
in combat and although inexperienced
they are well aware of the damage they
can inflict
russia's charge into combat exposed and
vulnerable
but they fight for honor and are more
than happy to die as heroes
their tanks use this size to intimidate
their enemies they maintain a strict
workout routine
in order to withstand the heavy armor
they wear for extended periods of time
but they aren't used to being stood up
to and are easily disoriented when
attacked head-on
alien b riflemen make up the bulk of
their forces they use assault rifles and
flashbang or stun grenades
they are well trained and should be
watched at all times as they are
constantly trying to flank enemies while
they're distracted
the lmb snipers are powerful and
accurate any threats caught out in the
open will quickly be downed
yet staying in the cover isn't the
answer either the l b scouts are fast
and will rush straight towards the enemy
with their semi-automatic shotguns
and if they fail there are the
grenadiers with grenade launchers
and heavy gunners laying down
suppressive fire from a medium range
on top of this they have medics with
powerful healing support stations
which will quickly undo any progress
made by the opposing force of lift
uncheck
and then there are the first wave rogue
agents who are deadly at all ranges
and utilize a number of shd tech to
further tip the battle in the lmb's
favor
the true sons are a group made up of a
mix between well-trained ex-military
personnel
police firefighters and other civilians
who have been absorbed into their ranks
while on paper that seems relatively
messy they more than make up for this in
their discipline
and overall coordination their leader
antoine ridgeway built a standard for
his troops that included consistent
military training
to keep them on track and battlefit
although their methods of recruiting
have led to a quality of member who was
prone to questionable acts of cruelty
and lethal punishment on the local
populace over time this has turned the
true sons into vicious and arrogant
bullies
intimidation and violence have become a
way of life for those in their area of
influence
they have no problems making examples
out of individuals to ensure obedience
then we have the last man battalion a
private military company consisting of
highly trained
former united states special forces
after the dollar flew struck new york
the lmb were brought back into the
country
to assist the wealthy they've returned
from conflict zones overseas
and they aren't particularly happy with
being thrown into the centre of where
the epidemic first started
compared to other factions in the
manhattan quarantine zones
the lmb had far more combat specialists
with top grade military gear and weapons
and their defensive positions were more
heavily fortified
after they were then abandoned by the
jtf they took it upon themselves to
correct the horrible job that the
government was doing
using their own form of strict martial
law they are prepared to use all means
necessary
to ensure that the city and then the
country survives these events
[Music]
although these two groups have a very
strong resemblance in their reasons
behind turning against the government
and even their methods of doing so are
relatively comparable to a certain
extent
this is where the similarities end based
on the points covered earlier on
the outcome here is fairly clear-cut and
one-sided
even if we remove the fact that they
have keen as rogue agents within their
ranks
the last man battalion out-does the true
sons in almost every scenario
from their training and background to
the weapons and technology
all the way through to their discipline
and loyalty
the only area where the true suns seem
to come out on top is through their
numbers
but even then past the initial uprising
of the jtf
most of these are convicts and general
civilians who have been forced to fall
in line
the fact that the lmb are a pmc who up
until recently were overseas in conflict
areas
only further supports how much more
prepared they are for the situation
they're in
we're the true sons a former jtf and we
know how well they've been doing
throughout all of this
if we were to heavily generalize private
military companies
they're also more used to being disliked
by the general population
and although this isn't always the case
with all of them pmcs are often more
heavily armed than general military
personnel
and probably one of the main things to
consider is that when pmcs are on
assignment
they are constantly under threat there
is no off time for them
where a soldier can return to a heavily
defended military camp when off duty
pmcs need to be prepared and ready at
all times
although they both have the same
motivations and roughly the same
techniques of achieving their goals
the l b really are on a different level
from the true suns
so with that in mind what would happen
hypothetically if we were to put them up
against another pmc
the black tusk anyway i hope you've
enjoyed this video
i'm loving the recap on some of these
factions that i haven't really talked
about for a while now
i'll catch in the next one cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]